Adrianne Haslet is not your typical
athlete she was hit by a terrorist bomb
at the finish line of the Boston
Marathon in 2013 and nearly six years
later a few blocks from the site of the
blast she was hit by a car despite
everything she's faced hasslin is
focused on turning her tragedies into
triumph April 15 2013 is a date Adrianne
Haslet will never forget that day she
was a spectator at the Boston Marathon
she was hit by shrapnel and ultimately
lost her left leg we first met houseless
three years ago something can happen to
you in three seconds but it's up to you
to make every single second count after
she was on the up and up accepting her
new normal as an amputee three years
after her life has changed she completed
the 2016 marathon even though she was
never a runner it was a brutal journey
to recovery but along the way she
allowed cameras to document the whole
process I was thankful that it was as
raw as it was and that I captured those
raw moments how has your life changed I
look at life so much differently now I
just feel this sort of understanding
about what it's like to go through
something really really tough you know
it's that phrase that everyone's
fighting a hard battle just as Haslet
was preparing for another marathon race
last month she was hit by a car another
devastating blow again to the left side
of her body
the accident left her in the hospital
for weeks in her case with those two
unspeakable and heard of tragedies that
most people will never experience you
know I think on the one hand she has a
depth of experience in recovering from
something that's this traumatic and on
the other hand this is a major challenge
and a tragedy in the middle of a
training cycle so we stopped re-evaluate
and go forward from here
like in tragedy before Haslet has shared
every step of her painful recovery on
social media showcasing unparalleled
optimism first shower on my own is this
fess she is adamant that this is not how
her story will end and for the first
time Adrianne Haslet will talk to us
about her recovery and whether she was
able will be able to run this year's
best in marathon it's an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
Adrienne it's so good to see you here in
person with Fred Astaire your service
dog thank you you how are you you know
I'm good today I've had worse days and
I've certainly had better days but I try
and make the day today better than
yesterday and today is mm-hmm you were
training to run this year's marathon
again I was and I was training to win
first in my division for mobility
impaired so not just run it but to place
mm-hmm and then you were hit by a car
yeah I was I can't eat listening to you
say that it doesn't even seem real yet
mm-hmm it's like you know you say Gail
was saying this earlier it's like first
a terrorist nearly killed you and then
you get hit by a car why me why me right
why me I mean it's so easy to get stuck
on that and I try not to but you can't
help it I mean who gets blown up by a
terrorist and hit by a car
I know this has been so painful for you
because I follow you on Instagram and
we've been friends for a while and I
know you were pouring your heart into
the Boston Marathon was are you going to
be able to run no no I'm not one of the
first time saying it out loud it's so
hard but I'm physically and mentally but
physically unable to do that I did such
little mobility in my arm and I've it's
65 days away today and I talked with my
coach and I talked with my surgeon and
I'm not running and I I am NOT gonna be
able to train for that kind of distance
mm-hmm and it's so impossibly hard to
have that taken away from me because it
was going to be the six-year anniversary
yeah it's falling on the day for the
first time of the 6-year anniversary and
to take back that day and to be running
as a thank you to everyone who supported
me in the running community and Boston
and Beyond I I just wanted to say thank
you you know I think about that you
saying - I wanted to take back that day
for myself one of the things you told me
that just
rings in my head is that you say I've
been broken mm-hmm but I'm more than my
broken pieces I am more than my broken
pieces yes I have now no left foot and I
have this gash scar on my arm which I
don't know what mobility I'll gain back
with PT eventually but I'm more than
that I'm so much more than that I had to
completely redefine myself after losing
my leg and I know I can do that again
after being hit by a car you also told
me I have chosen not to be a victim yes
that's a hard thing when you've
experienced what you've been through
yes and you know I choose to be called a
victim because I'm not defined by what
happened in my life I'm defined by how I
live my life but it is very difficult to
think that you are not a victim of
multiple multiple injuries and multiple
people telling you don't do this what
happened when the driver hit you I was
walking across the street directly in
front of my house just blocks away from
the finish line and out of nowhere and I
know that sounds crazy a car came and
hit me on my left prosthetic I still
have the dent Ben sent me flying in the
air the car did not have headlights on
it did not stop at the crosswalk I had
the right-of-way flew me in the air and
I remember looking down onto the vehicle
it was dark out and he did not have
lights on and I remember thinking I'm
going to land on my head and I tucked my
head down and I hit the left side of my
body and it shattered all of this here
and I sat up and I felt my arm my elbow
sitting in my lap even though it should
have been higher up and I knew that I
was - my arm was not attached to my body
in the ambulance first thing you think
of the surgeon that helped you with your
leg I did I called dr. Kalish my
Superman surgeon and I said something's
happen again I need you at the hospital
now get there I didn't even ask what is
the lesson that others who are dealing
with pain in different ways can learn
from your incredible resilience thank
you no I you know I don't have all the
answers but one thing that I'm proud of
is the to be fiercely protective of my
mental health I don't think it's
separate mental or physical for me I put
a note on the outside of the hospital
room and even
I was exposed to media I thought those
blasts came from the sky for about three
months I think it's you have to be
fiercely protective of who you surround
yourself with and who you invite into
your life and let yourself heal give
yourself the time and then you can do
anything
Thank You Adrianne Haslet thank you so
much for having me it's good to see you
again
and we'll be right back with more here
on CBS this morning
you